[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don Sakia today
we have the pleasure of sitting down
with the CEO of conscious capitalism
aleksandr makovan allen thank you so
much for having me boom I'm super
excited me too it's gonna be a great
episode so alex has been the CEO of
conscious capitalism for two years now
and we're gonna be talking about the
good that capitalism is as this driving
force for social change for good change
in the world elevating humanity through
business yes hear hear
thank you for coming onto the show again
thank you for having me I really
appreciate it so your background is also
cool cuz you were doing students for
liberty in DC for nine years and also at
the Cato Institute for a little bit so
why don't we you know you're born in
Pennsylvania that's right and then you
grow up there you tell you were
seventeen yep from York PA as in
peppermint patties and barbells
absolutely loved it there went to
college in Philly and then moved to DC
to work at the Cato Institute and then
go to grad school at Georgetown and I
really had no idea where life was going
to take me when I was growing up I
thought I would become an attorney
because I cared about principles like
justice and morality then I realized
what attorneys typically did so decided
I want to become a philosophy professor
huh then I realized what it meant to be
a philosophy professor and as much as I
loved reading and writing philosophy I
didn't want to do that for the rest of
my life so I decided to go into
organizing for profits and nonprofits in
order to bring about the principles in
the world that I wanted to see and
eventually that led me to conscious
capitalism yeah
that seemed like the perfect fit as you
were looking into law and then you're
like with a philosophy oh how do I
actually make the world better through
these principles that I have through
business this is it seems like the right
fit well what were you exactly studying
when you were in DC with students for
liberty the Cato Institute what exactly
was were you going through there so what
at Georgetown in my studies I was
focusing on business ethics actually
which helped lead me to conscious
capitalism the dissertation I wanted to
write before I decided to stop out of
graduate school was around a new theory
of corporate moral responsibility based
on the purpose of a business yes a
different way of thinking about why
businesses exist than what is typically
taught or articulated in the media it
was basically with shareholders and
money and then being bringing a product
or value to the world as kind of the
three things but then there's where is
the moral philosophy or the Shinhwa
desire for social good baked into that
why is it not there sometimes I think
it's this over economization of the
concept of business and corporations
themselves nowadays so that the business
itself is typically considered this
black box that you ultimately get
profits and revenue from and that's the
reason that they exist but if you talk
to entrepreneurs and ask them why they
start a business it's rarely just to
make a lot of money sure they want to
make money everyone does but it's
typically that they see a problem in the
world that they want to solve or there
is some value they want to instantiate
and they're looking to find a profitable
way to create a sustainable solution to
that in fact that's one of the best ways
to create a sustainable solution is to
develop a business model around it and
when you talk to everyday people who
maybe aren't running their own
businesses but they work for businesses
they interact with them on a daily basis
they don't care so much about the bottom
line that's typically taught in business
they're looking for their own particular
kinds of value with with them and it
really got me to rethink what is the
purpose of business and how do we
articulate the ethical requirements of
businesses and people
businesses based around this
intersection of interests and this
concept of business as a value creator
beyond just profit creator yep
and some business ethics I love that I
love that it just seems like there's not
enough people talking about that because
businesses in many essences what drives
the status of the world to have more
food have more water have more health
care education all these different
things so if that is if this is kind of
the foundational bedrock for flourishing
for societal flourishing then it's
really important that we instantiate
some sort of ethics into it but it's
different for every business owner as
well well but there are some core
principles that maybe one should
consider as maybe like consider
providing your employees with health
care they'll probably make them and
their families more stable and therefore
you can have build a better culture with
them as you move forward so so you need
so it's not like every business should
give health care but you recommend it
how do you go about something like that
so before we get into specific
applications let's start at the
foundations of capitalism and modern
business which actually had ethics baked
into it from the beginning and a sense
of a moral purpose to business that was
kind of lost by mainstream business in
the 20th century to a certain extent yes
Adam Smith the author of The Wealth of
Nations considered as a founder of
free-market capitalism
before he was an economist was an
ethicist he wrote a Theory of Moral
Sentiments before he wrote The Wealth of
Nations where he articulates how human
beings have a natural inclination to be
concerned for one another and ought to
be and that actually laid the foundation
for him to build a theory of economics
on top of that where people are
concerned with the interests of one
another and by looking out for their own
own interests they can better one
another and created the modern
capitalist system that or at least is
one of the founding fathers of it
intellectually so it was always in there
from the beginning but it's
a lot of people forgot about that
overtime and I think there are a number
of reasons for that including the over
economization over theorization of
business as we talked about before in
the 20th century and the ego and the
drive of the self because like you said
with Al Smith was focused on the other
the new king and the connection between
the two and there was the separation
that came into place here and that even
came about I think when business ethics
was introduced in business schools
originally over a hundred years ago
where the way that a lot of people talk
about business ethics I think is
inverted where they see ethics as a
constraint on the business profit
process that business itself is
inherently evil and destructive and
selfish and you need Ithaca --lc
instrumentos in business when really the
principles of business are inherently
good it's based on voluntary exchange
it's about making people better off
business is not competitive as most
people talk about but actually a very
collaborative so when you buy something
from someone else when you give your
money to them you say thank you at the
store and they say thank you in exchange
for giving you something that they've
created there's this inherent quality to
a business in capitalism that is
tremendous and can be unleashed and
business ethics to a certain extent can
play a role in not only articulating but
living that out more by providing
guidance for businesses to really
understand how they create more value
for everyone how they avoid harming
anyone in that process and make the
world in humanity itself better off from
that and so you're absolutely right that
this is going to vary from business to
business and business leader to business
leader they're going to have different
instantiations
of what we call the four principles of a
conscious business but it's all driven
around the idea of having the intention
of making the world better off making
everyone that the business touches
better off and and doing as best as one
can
for it and the last thing I'll say here
before I turn it back to you is that
this isn't a binary thing it's not that
there are good businesses and bad
businesses it's not that there are
conscious businesses and unconscious
businesses it's that it's a spectrum and
there are those businesses that are
trying to be conscious and do good and
are doing a better job of it
then and there are those that aren't
trying to be conscious and aren't trying
to do the right thing and are doing the
worst job of it and there's there's no
perfect conscious business out there we
never say there is and in fact a
business says that they are conscious
and they're perfect then that's probably
a red flag we want businesses and
business leaders involved in our network
who are trying to do better and that
want to utilize our community of
business leaders to become better
themselves so let's do let's do two
things so first let's explain that this
is a consultancy right then you guys go
and collaborate with these businesses
that want to become more conscious
they're they're aware that they want to
implement more of these conscious
principles your higher purpose
stakeholder orientation conscious
leadership conscious culture that those
principles and then you guys collaborate
with them on how to implement those into
their business so that's one of the
things that we do we're a service
oriented organization that's really
doing three things to elevate humanity
through business the first is build a
community of like-minded business
leaders because whether you're talking
about business school or the media or
just the social narrative most people
think the purpose of business is to make
as much money as possible by any means
necessary
it can actually be lonely for business
leaders to have a different way of
thinking about business where they have
a higher purpose they're driven by these
values so we want to make sure that
they're connected with peers who are
able to support them in this endeavor
who have been through the same
challenges that they're experiencing can
say I've been there here's some advice
on what to do and can just give them the
encouragement to go on the second thing
we do is provide learning and
development opportunities which includes
consulting work and includes also case
and workshops and just general
educational opportunities for businesses
to learn how to be more conscious so for
example coming up we've got business
leaders in our network visiting two of
the companies that have been actively
involved with us for a while
Barry Wayne Miller that has this
everybody matters philosophy that is
incredibly inspiring out in Wisconsin
and Greyston bakery in Yonkers New York
that has an open hiring policy where
they for 90% of their jobs don't have
any application or review process they
ask people to just write their name on a
list and when a job opens up they go
down the list call people up and say
we've got a job do you want it or not
and people get second or third chances
in life from that which just inverts the
hiring process on its head yeah yeah but
then the third thing we do also is
actively make the case for conscious
capitalism which means communications we
want to help tell the stories of
businesses that are making the world a
better place so more people realize how
business and capitalism can be this
force for good and encourage both those
people already in business to adopt
these practices as well as to have more
people go into business as a way of
making the world a better place so we
have the community we have the learning
and development programs and we have
communications communicating the mission
to more people yep of making the case
for conscious capital is 180 forward ok
cool
those are huge those are all huge the
community is really important and so are
they learning developer programs and
outreach all of it is okay so now let's
go back to Alex Smith Adam Smith adam
smith adam smith adam smith so wealth of
nations mm-hmm Adam Smith wealth of
nations wrote about it literally being
thinking about the other we need to have
some sort of a connection to the other
to help one another and then use
capitalism as a driving force for good
in that process then that was 1920s that
was 1776 actually what yeah
a long time ago that was 1776 yeah oh my
god
Wow that was at the founding of the u.s.
that time yeah they didn't even read the
book at that point it was published in
1776 Wow okay and then when did yeah
when did capitalism really end up I mean
the Industrial Revolution but when when
did yeah and then and then furthermore
about the even the most recent iteration
of the conscious capitalism book so
let's take us through that time period
so the late 18th century was this
interesting turning point in economics
around the world we still had feudalism
in large parts of Western Europe and in
the United States we even had slavery
still in the United States the idea of
moving away from a state based
conception of the economy that included
feudalism and mercantilism the
aggregation of precious resources that
would bolster the economy in most
people's minds was turned on its head by
Allen Smith who instead just Rican Sep
Chu alized how you even think about an
economy doing well which is based on how
the quality of life of the people in the
economy and when you take that standard
it requires you to think differently
about how people interact with one
another one another at the level of
business and economic transactions and
that was one of the first key steps in
coming to a into in creating an economy
based on making everyone's lives better
off and it led to tremendous human
flourishing it didn't change things
overnight clearly a lot of other things
had to happen there but things around
the world starting to get a lot better
in the two centuries since capitalism
was really developed we've seen average
life expectancy more than double from
thirty to sixty eight years we've seen
average GDP across the globe increased
by 1,000% literacy rates going from 16%
globally to 84 percent and poverty being
almost extinguished over the next 50
years we're actually on track to a
eliminate poverty and all of this
happening when back in the 18th and 19th
centuries most economists thought the
world couldn't handle more than a
billion people we have 7 billion now and
people's lives are still better off
thanks to the ability for people to
freely exchange with one another thanks
to capitalism but as much good as
capitalism is done for Humanity that
doesn't mean it's been perfect and it
doesn't mean that it is perfect right
now
there have been significant abuses of
businesspeople over the years there are
those who are engaged in rent seeking
and taking advantage of individuals and
frankly businesses that simply haven't
thought through a better way of doing
things than what was given to them
before again remember before capitalism
we had feudal economies and most
businesses when they were initially
developed in the 18th and 19th centuries
even into the 20th actually look very
futile in their structures as well
that's this top-down hierarchy one
person is in charge of everything tells
other people what to do and you have
long chains of reporting and
accountability that's feudalism new
businesses and the and the idea of
conscious capitalism is about not only
embracing what capitalism means but a
better way of thinking about human
interactions at a fundamental level how
do we actually empower people to have
rewarding experiences of business as
part of their whole life and bring the
whole person's into business which
includes rethinking the way businesses
are organized rethinking the way that we
do leadership rethinking business
strategy to include culture and as we've
been talking about just rethinking why a
business exists in the first place this
this history and the way that capitalism
has helped enhance and enrich humanity
through literacy and through poverty and
through all these life expectancy this
is crucial is crucial for people to
fully grasp and then to say that good ok
capitalism has helped us get there now
how can we do some more of that
consciously along the way
okay and then so then John Mackey wrote
CEO of Whole Foods with Raj Sisodia
wrote conscious capitalism what year did
they write that and then yeah tell us
about that so conscious capitals in the
book was published in 2013 John Mackey
the founder and CEO of Whole Foods Raj
Sisodia professor at Babson University
tremendous individuals co-authored that
and that was the book that really
started conscious capitalism Inc the
organization we are carrying on what was
articulated in that book deepening the
understanding and helping more business
leaders practice it but that book really
was the result of almost a decade's
worth of work to get to that point never
been business leaders practicing
conscious capitalism since there was
business and Adam Smith wrote The Wealth
of Nations there are business leaders
who have understood that you need to
have a higher purpose and stakeholder
orientation conscious leadership and
conscious culture there have even been
other ways of articulating this that
have been that have been prominent
before but conscious capitalism really
started to develop in the 2000s when
business leaders like John Mackey from
Whole Foods Kip Tindell from The
Container Store Doug rau from Trader
Joe's and others started to come
together and especially around the time
of the 2008 crisis say we really need to
articulate a different way of thinking
about business what the pundits are
talking about what has led to problems
in society is really this
misunderstanding and mischaracterization
misapplication of business we all know
what potential business has to make the
world a better place we need to share
that philosophy with other individuals
which led to the authoring of the book
the founding of conscious capitalism Inc
and everything that we're doing now and
what were some of the things that they
wrote about because they saw to it to
happen in 2008 they knew
needed to be communicated to other
businesses across the world and so what
did they write about and then how to
conscious capitalism kind of birth from
that so I'll actually take this time to
explain what conscious capitalism is
because we haven't talked about it much
yet what they really talked about were
these four principles of conscious
business that they then that they
articulated in the book eventually and
gave a name to conscious capitalism as
the integration of several movements
into one but the first thing they all
talked about was how the idea that the
reason a business exists is to make as
much money as possible it is wrong
that's not why entrepreneurs create
businesses that's not what people who
are the most passionate about businesses
are concerned with that's not what who
creates a thriving long lasting business
as well if a business is just out to
make money in fact that's actually a
pretty bad strategy for doing so it's
not that profit is a bad thing profits
great it's just that profit is a means
to some higher ends rather than
vice-versa a good analogy is the concept
of red blood cells for us as human
beings red blood cells are great we need
them to survive but just because we need
them to survive doesn't mean that our
purpose for existence is to create as
many red blood cells as possible it's
the same thing with profits and business
it's a it's a means to an end so then
what we talked about a lot on our show
is that Peter Thiel's has talked about
the benefits of paying CEOs little bits
of money or taking as little salary as
possible and then keeping that fire
really brightly burning under their ass
to keep making the impact on the world
and even in general you know Ron and I
have a lot of conversation about the
importance of you know not owning boats
their cars or watches or houses or any
of this stuff just you know renting
things like what through the through the
shared economy when needed but but
really just to
taking keep take away from of of that
whole it's good for the economy thing
and rather focus on you know what's good
for my spirituality or what's good for
my essence or my being because taking
myself away from those material sick
possessions and not focusing on the
amount of money that I earn through my
paycheck but rather the impact that I
make on the world is really important
and so the whole thing about like can
this entity function to continue
investing all the money that it earns
back into impacting the world and then
we just you know live and and eat and
that's you know and take care of
ourselves and that's pretty much it you
know rather than rather than trying to
take the money earn to try and do
something materialistic or that actually
doesn't advance our purpose our impact
well just because we don't want to own a
boat it doesn't mean that we don't want
to have a friend that owns a big boat
just don't forget that just because we
don't want it it doesn't mean that you
know we can't have it or that we can
rent boats needed further for a day you
know you can rent a boat for whatever a
couple hundred bucks rather than wanting
to own a boat which depreciate as an
asset which costs thousands of dollars a
year to manage it just it's and ya know
there's so so yeah so the impact putting
the impact first as a business is seems
to be really crucial and not focusing on
your personal bottom line absolutely and
it actually has this counterintuitive
effect of making your bottom line better
off - it's not that businesses that are
conscious sacrifice profit this is
actually a way to make a more profit
especially over the long run you know I
mentioned before I almost became a
philosophy professor there is this
concept in philosophy called the
Happiness paradox where as a person if
you want to be as happy as possible the
worst possible thing you can do is to
make decisions based on what's going to
make you happy if you spend a weekend
just trying to be as happy as you can be
in that moment you're going to be pretty
sad and broke at the
whereas people who adopt some other
higher purpose to their being if whether
it's an ideal family or a cause actually
tend to be an are generally happier in
their lives so it's not that profits a
bad thing it's not the happiness is a
bad thing it's that making decisions
based on that and saying that's why you
exist is boat is both wrong and probably
not gonna actually lead to you being
happier profitable in the long run I
like how you put this values first or
these first principles idea again it
seems to be getting more and more baked
into our show over time but if you do go
into life with an understanding that I
want to you know make the world better
in this certain way or that I want to do
this every day with my time and you go
from that sort of value system first
then you're going to see this you know
the short-term picture this
moment-to-moment picture in this
long-term picture of of what you're
doing for the world what you're doing
for other people why that's so important
rather than like you said just going for
the weekend just like how can I be as
happy as possible and then try and and
just figure it out so so what's great is
that this also aligns everyone who
interacts with the business to
understand what they're trying to
accomplish and get out of it which leads
to the second thing that these business
leaders started to talk about which is
that typically in business you're taught
that a business is ultimately
accountable to the shareholders to
investors that's the only stakeholder
that really matters and managers are
agents of the shareholders and need to
always look out for their interests and
as a result created this idea that the
resources in a business are inherently
finite and if you're going to benefit
another group say employees or customers
or vendors you must be taking away from
the shareholders in some way and that's
bad
well that that seemed and is flawed to
everyone who is starting conscious
capitalism they had a different
perspective that we teach which is that
instead of taking up the perspective
that one
most important everyone else is a means
to that and you need to make trade-offs
all the time to support that one group
that the business ought to create value
for everyone involved and we can
actually grow the size of the pie that
benefits everyone yeah
so this is called stakeholder
orientation where businesses should look
at every group and individual they touch
and strive to make them better off
because the business exists yeah and
find creative ways for there to be
win-win-win solutions to problems so
that by providing a benefit to a vendor
you actually help employees out or by
helping the customers you make
shareholders better off and again
customers employees shareholders this
win-win-win yeah exactly and again it's
not the shareholders or investors or bad
or that you shouldn't be concern of them
it's just that that's not the only group
to be concerned with and you shouldn't
try to balance off benefits to different
groups but instead find ways that
everyone wins from yep and then if you
figure out how to nail that that
relationship you can grow the entirety
of the pie over time even faster and
then and you know good okay so then that
stakeholder orientation I think we
talked a little bit about the higher
purpose so that what we were talking
about with the weekend versus having
something of a value system and then
what about the conscious leadership and
conscious culture within the
organization so when people think about
business that leaders they're typically
thinking either about management just
controlling resources to maximize a
certain end or if they talk about
leadership they're often focused on one
of two types of intelligence is analytic
intelligence where you're able to make
trade-offs and understand how to
conceptualize the world in a way that
grows the business or emotional
intelligence which has been getting a
lot more attention over the last couple
of decades where people understand their
own emotions the emotions of others and
are able to lean into that to fully
present themselves as a whole person but
there are two other types of
intelligences that we think need to be
brought into leadership that aren't
talked about
one is systemic intelligence so it's a
lot easier to be an emotionally
intelligent person in one-on-one or
three-person interactions bless you
versus versus with 300 people or 3,000
people and making and finding creative
win-win solutions at that level versus
when it is just three people that's a
lot more difficult it's a much deeper
skill but something that conscious
leaders need to develop and going even a
step above that spiritual intelligence
isn't a religious concept but the idea
that leaders need to embody the values
of the organization that they're a part
of and model how to be a leader and how
to really represent the business and be
there to everyone else to their
employees their shareholders their
customers yeah and developing all of
these intelligences leads one to be a
conscious leader who is able to not just
have an an organization run but thrive
and the corollary to leadership which is
necessary for a business to thrive is
the culture now most business schools
and people rightly focus on the business
plan or strategy of the organization and
spend a lot of time developing those and
that is important you need to have a
revenue model you need to have a plan of
action but day-to-day few people are
referencing the annual business plan to
make their decisions they're not citing
policies to decide who they're going to
talk to to get things done or what are
the appropriate interactions or how they
treat one another that's all cultural
it's the interactions that people have
when management's not looking when
they're not referencing the business
plan and that can be and typically is
far more important to the success of a
business than whatever it's official
strategy actually is and conscious
cultures are ones where people are able
to bring their whole selves in that
develop authentic trusting relationships
as well as accountability so that people
are
accomplishing the mission and purpose of
the business at the end of the day and
we want more businesses to really lean
into that and think about what kind of
culture that do they have and how do
they make it as supportive a culture
that creates this productive environment
at the end of the day I really like how
you said there's analytical intelligence
of an emotional intelligence think
that's a really important thing that we
talked about on the show a lot and then
the more that we talk about that and
really implement emotional intelligence
into more of our engagements
interactions with the world with ourself
with the inter management and with
collectivism both that that's a good
really good way for us to progress in
the future I'm glad you brought that up
and then I'm glad you brought up the
trusting workplace bringing your
authentic self to the workplace that
seems to be over and over again
something that's crucial that gets that
gets thwarted a lot limited and if we
can build cultures where that is totally
cool to be yourself and to but to also
be emotionally intelligent when it comes
to learning things from other people or
to or to just you know being playful and
dancing through work and but also being
you know very analytical when you need
to get something done as well so this is
good this is really good I think that's
pretty good
all right is there something else about
conscious capital that you want to
mention before I ask you a couple of our
simulation questions the only thing I
would say that we've kind of touched on
already is that conscious capitalism it
says take some unique position almost
that says capitalism is great it's done
amazing things for Humanity but it can
be better when we lean into the human
nature of business and capitalism which
is what distinguishes this way of
thinking about business from most others
we unleash its potential to make
humanity better off to make everyone's
lives better off and so it's really
about taking all of this to the next
level
to better people's lives yeah and that's
I love it it's like an iteration of
capitalism adding in this this
this more goodness of this more
collective goodness taking employees
customers and shareholders all up
together over time I love it all right
so so I guess the the first thought at
that I think would be important to ask
you about is there seems to be a severe
concentration of wealth that's occurring
and even though the pink are Givens true
that everybody's coming up over time the
severe concentration of wealth
exacerbated by information technology
seems to be almost specie aiding us and
either ultra rich or the ultra poor do
you what do you think about wealth
inequality what do you think we're just
gonna solve it over time what would be
your thoughts around it maybe a solution
I think it's a real issue that we're
facing today that has a myriad of
contributing factors to this but one of
them that I don't think is discussed
nearly enough is how unconscious ways of
thinking about business has led to this
kind of result and oftentimes it's
simplistic approaches to compensation
and structuring payments and things like
that that have contributed to this issue
right now so for example CEO
compensation across the globe is greater
than it's ever been before and the
disparity between top paid CEOs and
lowest paid workers is more significant
than ever before how did we get here
when a CEO compensation used to be much
lower
well it's typically because boards
especially public companies want to make
want to make sure people think that they
are hiring the best person possible and
they and a way to symbolize that is by
how much they pay them and in order to
figure out what their peers are being
paid and what expectations are there
they get consulting firms to come in
evaluate what
standard compensation is okay we're
gonna hire someone and well we don't
want to get a B or C CEO so we can't pay
them at the bottom of the scale we have
to pay them at the top and it creates
this ratcheting effect that over time
has led to massive payments without
people really reflecting upon is this
actually right and it was based on good
intentions getting highly-skilled
executives to come in and run thriving
businesses to help people out but it's
had this unintended consequence that no
one is that no one has really railed
back against we need to address the same
thing goes with the way that we think
about compensation not just for
executives but everyone in companies
often times we think in the shareholder
orientation way of viewing business that
well if you pay people more that you're
taking money away from shareholders and
you you can't do that instead of what
some businesses have actually done which
is show that by paying people more at
the lowest levels in a company you
actually get better workers and you have
better returns that delivers to other
people and that this is a strategy in
business we really have to think about
how businesses can lean in to their
purpose how they compensate people being
very thoughtful about what are the
incentive structures that leads to
inequality and compensation and the and
then later on the inequality in the
world and how business can actually work
to address this I'm glad that you loop
that back into the way that business has
potentially caused inequality in some
ways as well I think that's that's
really important as shareholders decide
to maximize their profits and add an
extra zero to the end of their paychecks
what ends up happening is there is a
severe disconnect between them and the
employees and then the customers and
then also the rest of the world that
desperately needs the attention of that
extra zero to try and actualize them
maybe they then become your customers as
well maybe they then become some
employees within the organization as
well so there's this whole different way
to look at things if one's willing to
wander down
that path and I do think that there has
been some ways that capitalism has
exacerbated wealth inequality it's
exacerbated problems with the
environment with sustainability for
example using plastics rather than
biodegradable x' because we want to
maximize our profit because we don't
want to pay the extra nickel or dime or
quarter that we need in order to use a
degradable polymer that can just more
easily decompose in a landfill than
plastic can we wouldn't have the Pacific
Garbage Patch these-these repercussion
based society the way that you just
travel on a on a navy vessel across the
ocean and then whenever you have garbage
just toss it overboard into the ocean
that does not seem like we thought about
that ahead of time we just we just
didn't think about that ahead of time
and these sorts of ways of thinking
about things ahead of time with the
Design Thinking mindset about how is a
system designed is going to be crucial
moving forward to prevent inequality to
prevent this is the next question how do
the u.s. collaborate with China and
Russia and the Middle East and all these
other developing areas of the world as
we progress moving forward how do you
see a potentially a communist
authoritarian Republic working with a
democratic capitalist one so I want to
touch on the environmental degradation
point for a moment as well because
that's something that more businesses
are starting to lean into especially
businesses that take a stakeholder
orientation mindset the environment is a
stakeholder that businesses need to be
concerned about as well they need to
make the environment better off then how
they came to it if they're actually
being a conscious business yeah and the
beforehand I think there was less
consciousness about the impact on the
environment there certainly wasn't an
internalization of negative
externalities that needs to take place
which led to
pollution like you're talking about and
taking this stake this stakeholder
orientation approach again with the idea
that we can actually make the
environment better through our business
and make ourselves better with it is
just a completely different way of
thinking about it than what people were
taught in the 20th century this
trade-off mindset and that's what we
need in order to move past these
problems in order to solve them going
forward and that may actually be a good
segue into answering your question about
how capitalist countries are able to
work with authoritarian countries which
is to basically have this higher sense
of purpose and a higher understanding of
how business works and what a conscious
business means whereby conscious
businesses should be able to work with
people across borders and across
different types of economics
ridiculously challenging to figure out
how to get this free trade to actually
be loving and caring across countries
across this big ocean it seems to be
this nightmare of a conversation and
it's because people have this trade-off
mindset still where they think in order
for China to do better they must be
taking something from us instead of
recognizing that when we have trade and
when shut that means when China does
better we do better as well and even if
they may impose certain restrictions
that that's harming themselves as much
as it's harming us and taking that
higher sensibility and that better
understanding that we need to encourage
interactions and be a model for what
economics and business should be like in
the world that I see that's really the
way forward it was interesting because
this time this thought this mindset of
wanting to be the leaders in the way
that we advanced democratic capitalism
through the world is also being impeded
/ sidelined by this desire for
conspicuous consumption it's really
difficult to
to tell people in the US that hey you
know Apple and Google and these
companies that manufacture the devices
that you put in your pocket every single
day they give you the access to what you
need that they are going to need to
start charging maybe three hundred
dollars more per device because they're
moving all their manufacturing back to
the United States because they want to
it's good you're providing something for
people across the seas but you're also
creating this dependency on other people
there's all the other conversations
about where the materials are being
mined from and how that's affecting
those areas and the kids that are
involved in that process and the
suicides they're involved the assemblies
there's all of so so this is difficult
because people want their devices people
want their watch as they want their cars
and boats they want these things and as
you as we develop more and more of this
want it's impeding or sidelining our
ability to figure out how to work
together and to flourish as a collective
as much as we flourish individually and
as much as you when you're looking at
the Earth from the moon there are no
[ __ ] borders on the planet and I'm
really really careful about how I speak
about this because I know that China's
doing a lot of things to the US that
they kind of want to rebirth the Chinese
amazingness into the world and I think
that's important but it's also very
important that the US with our
Constitution and our principles that I
think many people around the world think
is much better than authoritarian
regimes is much better than dictatorial
regimes that needs to continue making
sure that the US doesn't lose its
positioning because all of a sudden the
earth could have another moment of
dictatorship or of authoritarianism and
that's the last thing you want to do
when you're able to just wake up in the
morning and walk out the door and have a
good time getting a little bit of food
doing a little bit of work that you find
meaningful or valuable and that's all of
a sudden taken away from you because now
you
a top-down power that's telling you that
you have to do something that that is
very scary so I'm the globalization
conversation is it's very nuanced very
complex and I think that conscious
capitalism has a lot to do with the way
that we can move forward in a way of
higher purpose higher mission our value
is more social good I think that's
absolutely right the answer to countries
that are not practicing conscious
capitalism but perhaps the exact
opposite actually
conscious authoritarianism is not to
sink to that level and try to fight
there the answer in order for the United
States to remain a global leader is to
actually take this all-encompassing
mindset that the United States has
become a global leader by helping the
world become better off by doing this
thriving economy which may have involved
some unconscious capitalism for a little
while but can do even more now with
conscious capitalism and lean into being
a moral leader that has conscious
businesses driving the economy not just
for the US but for the globe for being a
model that others are able to embrace
and using that as a way to make the
whole world better off I'm imagining
right now this tutorial regime somewhere
in the world being overthrown by
conscious capitalism because people
because people went from ground up you
know it's difficult to do that who's
gonna be overthrown if that's what
you're imagining what company is going
to be overthrown oh and I ask you that
question Oh a dictatorial regime would
be overthrown so a top-down control
structure would be overthrown by people
especially by some place like the United
States saying like hey these are our
principles of conscious capitalism and
the other people around the world are
like whoa I'm gonna start implementing
that into my business in that country
and then yada yada and it's it's
difficult to exactly explain how it
would happen but I imagine that being
something of communicating of values
across the world yeah what do you think
I
mr. McCullen I've haven't heard anyone
else talk about conscious capitalism and
yeah it's it's it's actually true though
you know really the the the conversation
that we've had on the show sometimes
have to do with with cap with capitalism
and with making the world a better place
and figuring out how to do that but to
actually put the word conscious in front
of capitalism and at least have that
discussion and then propagate that
discussion through the world so crucial
well if you know we don't let people
like Alexander go forward we were gonna
get rolled over if we don't let right
yeah yeah exactly him to influence and
those in positions of power exactly and
it's not just about political regimes
it's about the businesses within those
regimes as well that you were mentioning
before the wave the way that you change
those is by modeling a better way of
doing business that actually makes
people's lives better off that makes the
business better off as well by helping
other people out the more that we're
able to spread this model spread this
message the the better everyone is going
to be do you think that we're alone in
the cosmos I think that's a difficult
question to answer I'm not sure do you
think there's an advanced civilization
that's roaming the cosmos I do see the
bug behind you do you believe that we
are in a computer simulation and that is
it for my philosophy days question that
we would ask wait a bit yeah are you
gonna answer that one or the cosmic 100
answer both which is that I I think the
probability is there that we are not
alone and there's also a probability
that this is not the end-all be-all but
not really sure what it would mean for
this to be the end-all be-all this is
what we have right now and that's a
pretty good place for us to work from
and trying to figure out why we're here
what we're trying to make of all of this
and if there are other beings out there
well we haven't interacted them yet but
if we do that that's going to be
interesting and also changed the way
that we think about why we're here and
what
joke's on you because we have a quantum
computer in the back that's simulating
the universe right now okay what do you
think's the most beautiful thing in the
world love hands down caring for another
person or another or another creature
just passionately and with that as an
end in itself as much as yourself for
more how can anything be more beautiful
than that I love Chinese food what about
that love and food itself is pretty good
too and that matters all right and then
how about what is something that you
believe to be true that almost nobody
else believes to be true mmm I don't
know if almost no one else believes this
to be true but I think it goes my live
conscious capitalism but the idea that
money is a good thing at its root at its
core the concept of money is a
representation of value it's about value
that someone has created that you're
exchanging with another person in order
to to drive value from them and vice
versa it it isn't always used that way
and a love of money without
understanding that concept of value is
problematic in the same way that you
know pursuing profit as an end in itself
is problematic but profit itself is not
bad it's a good thing it's a nuanced
perspective perhaps but taking the
position that money and profit are good
things and we need to understand how
they're good in order to lean into that
I think is tremendously important I
can't believe that this was 1776 on an O
so throughout the wealth of nations yeah
I can't believe it was that long ago and
that the whole premise was to take care
of other people and that capitalism
could help us take care of each other
better and that's kind of what you ended
with there and I'm really happy that you
know Whole Foods Container Store these
different CEOs have this important
vision for a better
in conscious capitalism it's actually I
pretty much rarely see a Whole Foods or
Trader Joe's worker that's like pissed
off or that's like angry actually it
seems to be a fairly good culture there
don't we support The Container Store
are you we buy six dollars a piece or
something yeah yeah we do we do we
support Trader Joe's he just got some
Parmesan cheese from where'd you get the
pickles also Trader Joe's camera oh nice
I wasn't aware I know we stopped fooling
them yeah manhattan-style way to go
Salma Breiner e yeah we know them for
sponsorship yeah exactly yeah no fruit
no free plugs no reflux okay so this has
been a blast Alex thank you for coming
on - no no thank you I greatly
appreciate you so much we appreciate
conscious capitalism so much we
appreciate sharing this message as other
people building the community we'd love
to join the community of the leaders
around the Bay Area that are discussing
comments get yours balls let's do it
let's get more of them onto the show and
talking about it and then let's let's
share the message with more people
around the world so everyone thank you
so much for tuning in if you guys had a
good time give us a like and comment to
subscribe smash that subscribe button
okay
we need to grow we need to share this
content with more people around the
world so join us in that pursuit have
these tough conversations have these
conversations with people around you
inspire them expand their minds to new
dimensions join us on patreon we need
help with our rent with our production
cost with our food with our electricity
join us there so that we can continue
being an independent entity thank you
very much around Vargas our producing
partner and much love to everyone we'll
see you again soon
[Music]
[Music]